the Joe Rogan experience at a joke in
the old set that'll probably retired now
that we're all for what I do instead of
for eight weeks at least eight weeks man
when I mean I believe it's probably
gonna be several months before you know
easily could be longer it could be you
know maybe they find medication that
even though there's not a vaccine
there's some hope for a few different
kinds of medication one of them is a
malaria drug i don't can't pronounce the
name off the top of my head and there's
another one that shows promise as well
and they think that it might be possible
that people could catch this then you
would give them the medication it would
wipe it out there's also there was some
speculation about Tamiflu but i don't
think there's any conclusive evidence
that shows that Tamiflu helps it but
there is some these anti-malarial
medications i think that they think has
promised but what concerns me is it
seems to be so different with different
people that's what's weird about this it
makes it it's like what's scary right
now for everybody is the unknown like
we're in the unknown like now we've
never been in this situation before as a
culture we're on lockdown and the whole
world scared of a disease not not in our
lifetimes i mean not since like the
spanish flu and back then there wasn't
as much transportation there wasn't as
much distribution of information so
people probably weren't as aware as we
are now you know of all the various
cases all around them all the time
because you know we're hearing about
cases in italy and [ __ ] australia
everywhere we're hearing about cases all
over the planet i don't think that was
the case back during the Spanish flu
days I think was probably harder to
understand what was happening right
because there you probably only got the
newspaper and the radio back that and
everybody had a huddle around at a
certain time and those are the Masters
of information whatever they said that
was it but now you get all sorts of
conflicting information from doctors man
I've read doctors that think it's
nothing and then I've read doctors that
were terrified it's like wow this is
nuts
and then you know you look at I don't
know if you've been paying attention to
what these senators did but there's some
senators they had a behind closed
doors meeting about the coronavirus in
China and what it could meet the United
States and you know the various impacts
and they went out and sold their stock
immediately dude and then at the same
time they were talking about how under
control the government had it and how
we're prepared and how it's gonna be
fine and meanwhile they knew they knew
so they had two phases they had a public
face that they're given to us to try to
keep us calm and then they had a private
face which realized that the stock
market was going to take a huge loss and
so they sold everything and made immense
profits based on the information that
they found out from these closed-door
meetings about the coronavirus how are
they supposed to is that legal how are
they supposed to handle though out of
life legally what are they supposed to
do confusing I don't know what
constitutes insider trading how does
that work do you understand how that
works like if you have information that
can allow you to make money
well isn't that like what everyone's
trying to do like if like what is the
point of playing the stock market if you
don't know things and if you do know
things so if you know more because you
know the guy was the president he tells
you something about something they're
gonna do and you're not supposed to
trade then because of that information
like all right ok you know I'm sure
there's a logic to it I'm a [ __ ] don't
run it by me but if that's insider
trading well what is it what the
senators do if they knew that the
coronavirus was gonna wreck our economy
if they knew that it was coming down
like a [ __ ] storm of hail that no one
could stop if they knew and then they
bailed out and made immense profits that
seems so shady
it seems so shady that they didn't
advise people like you're supposed to be
a leader right if you're in a position
an elected representative you're
supposed to be acting in the position of
a leader and if your way to lead is tell
people one thing but act in a completely
different direction tell people
everything's gonna be fine but then
start selling your stock at a profit and
you don't tell other people to do it
because you're worried that maybe that
information is gonna cause some ripple
effect and it's gonna destroy the
economy even before the coronavirus hits
just had a panic and fear and people
gonna act wrong but you acted in a
different way than the way you were
talking you acted like this [ __ ] was
gonna be real you act like there's gonna
be a real problem and then the question
is like how
a problem did they think it was gonna be
maybe they dumped their stock they
thought it's gonna be a little problem
would that be okay well but if they
found I was gonna be a huge problem then
it's not well that seems weird to me to
like I don't know what should the rules
be with information in the stock market
the stock market is gross like it's the
whole thing is gross like what are we
basing our economy on this [ __ ]
madness this is it's not but it's not
the way that the 2000 2009 breakdown was
2008 when the stock market crashed it
was based on literal numbers and and
investments this is based no no I would
actually say that one was more real than
this one this is a the stock markets
crashed in a way that you're going like
it's based on I mean I I know that it's
it's for commercial businesses their
loans gonna come up and it's gonna be
tough for them but at some point you're
like I wish you could just put it all
freeze and go hey let's come back in
like two months
let's start where we were let's make
sure everyone was fed like that's but
birth is the ultimate real because if
it's supposed to be about confidence and
things rising and falling this is like
the ultimate expression of that there's
no confidence you can't work if it
doesn't crash here that it's nonsense
yeah then what's the point because
there's times where everything's groovy
people are buying like crazy hmm
manufacturing is up everything's up
everybody's happy consumer satisfaction
is up and people are buying like crazy
and there's so many industries that are
happening and there's so many jobs and
unemployment to the lowest rate it's
ever been ever in the history of people
and then all the sudden it's not anymore
or of course it's got a crash so it's
gonna crash this is the crash this is
the big one this is the big one of our
lifetime maybe the biggest one ever
because this [ __ ] could go on for a long
last time this is scary - did you think
of all those people just like who are
paycheck to paycheck you know with
waiting tables or teaching a spin class
or whatever it is all right that's where
my brain goes is like how come there's
gotta be a way to [ __ ] help people
mmm yeah that does I mean I that's all I
do all day is spend like the other day I
hit at McDonald's I was like say there's
a way to buy a bunch of Happy Meals I
could send to a neighborhood
you could do that with certain
restaurants you could support
restaurants one of my favorite
restaurants in Vegas gitanos is in
Henderson and they used to be in
Calabasas we just go to them way back in
the day but they're they're doing a lot
of takeout and then they're also raising
money for their employers which is very
nice yeah you know and I think the
store's doing something like that we're
all gonna donate for the waitstaff you
know because the waitstaff is completely
[ __ ] out of luck and they were doing you
know good business down there and so
those folks I'm sure they have bills
like serious [ __ ] bills and it's just
piling up and there's no business you
know I mean they went from having this
great place we can go and you can count
on X amount of money per week to all the
sudden gone and no one saw it coming
that's never happened ever you can't
blame them for not being prepared but
you know they're part of our comedy
family man we got a we got to take care
of them particularly at the store we
should set up something for the improv
too and we should also you know just
figure out a way to you know it's like
find out who's hurting like who's in
trouble
okay in our community a comics that we
know that our people are too proud I
know but we not find them though because
there's a lot of comics in our community
they're like they're going check to
check - you know middles middle acts
yeah now that headliners yeah there's a
lot of headliners right particularly
first few year headliners with you only
makin you know X amount of per week and
you know you got to pay your own flight
and all that jazz you're getting by but
you're not killing it and then you you
probably have [ __ ] an apartment it
cost two grand a month or more you know
I mean New York City those guys the
[ __ ] apartments in New York City are
ridiculous
[Applause]